All right.
Where I left off in the last
presentation I was dropping a
penny from the top of a
building-- once again, you
should not do, because you
can kill somebody.
Here's the building, and here's
the bad person who's
going to drop something.
Let's say they just hold it
out, and the penny drops.
The penny is going to accelerate
at the rate of
gravity, so it's going to
accelerate downwards at 10
meters per second squared.
Let's start with an interesting
question.
After after two seconds-- and
lets say they drop it right at
t equals 0-- so after two
seconds how fast is it going?
Time is equal to two seconds--
we could even say this change
in time, but we're assuming that
we're starting at time
equals 0, so and change in
time the same thing.
If time is equal to two seconds,
how fast is it going
to be going after two seconds?
Let's use that formula.
Velocity is equal to
acceleration-- acceleration is
the acceleration of gravity,
and that's 10 meters per
second squared-- so velocity
will be 10 meters per second
squared times time, which
is times two seconds.
We can multiply the numbers,
and you get 20.
Just like the numbers, you can
treat the units almost like
variables-- the seconds is the
same thing as this s, so this
s is going to the numerator, and
then you have an s squared
in the denominator.
This s will cancel out with one
of the two s's that are
multiplied down here, so we'll
end up-- actually, let me
write it down-- it'll be 10
meter seconds per second
squared, and that's the
same thing as 20.
That cancels out, this makes
that 1, and so that equals 20
meters per second.
Hopefully, you're starting to
get a little intuition of why
acceleration's units are meters
per second squared.
After two seconds, we're going
20 meters per second.
Let me ask you a slightly more
difficult problem that might
have not been obvious to you.
After two seconds, how far
has the penny gone?
This is interesting.
We have this formula here:
distance is equal to velocity
times time, but the velocity is
changing the entire time.
We know after two seconds that
the velocity is 20 meters per
second, so we could call this
the final velocity-- we'll
called v sub f.
That's just a fancy way of
saying final velocity.
Right when we start
at t equals 0,
what was the velocity?
Right when it started, the
initial velocity-- v sub i,
for initial-- is equal to
0 meters per second.
Can we use this formula?
You might think of a way
to already do it.
Since the acceleration is
constant, and you can only do
this when the acceleration is
constant-- most of what you'll
encounter in a first year
physics course, the
acceleration will be constant,
and especially when you're
dealing with gravity, the
acceleration will be
constant-- you can actually take
the average velocity to
figure out the distance.
So what was the average velocity
over the two seconds?
My final velocity was 20 meters
per second, and my
initial velocity was 0
meters per second.
Obviously, I went continuously
over those two seconds from 0
to 20, so my average velocity--
actually, I've
never seen it done this way
before, but let's just call it
average velocity-- is equal to
the final velocity plus the
initial velocity divided by 2.
I just took the average of the
initial and the final, which
is 20 plus 0-- which is 20--
divided by 2, which is equal
to 10 meters per second.
Right when I let go of the rock,
the ball, or the penny,
whatever I'm dropping, the thing
is stationary, and so
it's 0 meters per second.
After two seconds-- we used this
acceleration formula--
after two seconds,
it accelerated to
20 meters per second.
Over the course of those two
seconds, its average velocity
was 10 meters per second.
We can now use that average
velocity in this
formula right here.
The average velocity, distance
equals average velocity times
time-- you can make a mental
footnote, so it's average
velocity times time when the
velocity is changing and
acceleration is constant, which
is most of what you'll
see in most projectile
motion problems.
Now we could say distance is
equal to the average velocity
times time, which equals 10
meters per second times two
seconds-- once again,
the s's cancel out--
so we're at 20 meters.
After two seconds, not only is
my velocity 20 meters per
second down-- once again, if I
said speed, it would just be
20 meters per second-- but my
distance is the ball, or the
rock, assuming no
air resistance,
has dropped 20 meters.
Hopefully, that makes a little
bit of intuition for you.
If you are taking physics--
which you don't have to view
these videos, that's the idea--
I wanted to show you
that this is actually exactly
like one of the formulas that
you'll see in your
physics class.
It's kind of a shame, but people
tend to just memorize
it in physics without-- when
they're learning projectile
motion without really
appreciating that it just
comes from distance is equal
to velocity times time.
Before, I said velocity
is equal to
acceleration times to time.
Let me just expand that a little
bit, because I assume
that my initial velocity is 0.
Let me just say that the final
velocity is equal to the
initial velocity, because you
could already be going 10
meters per second, and then
you're going to accelerate.
Final velocity is equal to the
initial velocity-- this is an
i-- plus acceleration
times time.
We said that the distance-- we
could rewrite this as the
distance is equal to the average
velocity times time.
I just realized how funny
that character looks.
So, the final velocity is equal
to the initial velocity
plus acceleration times time,
and the distance is equal to
the average velocity
times time.
Let's see if we can use these
two formulas, which we
essentially just applied in
the previous example-- we
didn't do it exactly so
formally-- to come up with a
formula for distance, given
acceleration and time.
We know that the average
velocity-- oh, I switched
colors-- the average velocity is
equal to the final velocity
plus the initial velocity
divided by 2.
What is the final velocity?
The final velocity is equal to
this: substitute, and so the
initial velocity plus
acceleration times time plus
the initial velocity-- my i's
are getting blurred, they're
not showing up-- these are all
i's for initial velocity.
They look like a 2, but I
think you get the idea--
that's all initial velocity.
All of that is over 2.
The average velocity is equal
to the initial velocity plus
acceleration times time, plus
the initial velocity, all of
that divided by 2.
That just equals 2 times initial
velocity-- that looks
like an i now-- plus
acceleration times time
divided by 2, and that equals
the initial velocity plus
acceleration times time
divided by 2.
This might be intuitive for you,
as well, that the average
velocity is equal to your
initial velocity plus-- this
is essentially the difference
between how much you're
accelerating over that time and
speed is going to be that
divided by 2, because we're
taking the average.
If what I just said confused
you, don't worry about it; you
could just backtrack into
what we said before.
Think about a lot of these
formulas yourself, and plug in
numbers, and I think it'll
start to make more sense.
We figured out that the average
velocity is equal to
the initial velocity plus
acceleration times time.
We can just substitute
that back into
this original equation.
Once again, I realized I'm
running out of time, so I'll
see you shortly.